- We're now going to talk about one
of the most famous operons,
and this is the lac operon,
and it is part of E. coli's genome
and it is involved.
And the lac right over here
is referring to lactose,
and so you can imagine that it codes
for genes involved in the
metabolism of lactose.
And the word lactose might
already be familiar to you.
It is a sugar found in milk.
Some of us, including myself,
are lactose intolerant.
I have trouble digesting lactose,
so I have mixed feelings regarding this.
But in general, for a
cell to make use of it,
it needs to be able to absorb the lactose.
It needs to be able to split
it up into simpler sugars
that it can actually use for fuel,
and that is what the genes
in the lac operon actually do code for.
So just as an example, the
lac Z gene right over here,
this codes for an enzyme
that helps cleave the
lactose into simpler sugars.
The lac Y gene codes for an enzyme
that allows for the absorption of lactose
through cellular membranes.
Lac A is a little bit more interesting
and a little less understood,
but the general idea here is
all three of these are involved
in the metabolism and the
absorption of lactose.
And it is an operon,
so we have our promoter here
where our RNA polymerase would attach,
and I've also drawn some other sites.
I've drawn the operator right over here
where you can imagine a repressor,
indeed the lac repressor could bind,
and over here, this CAP
site, or C-A-P site.
CAP stands for Catabolite
Activator Protein.
Catabolite,
Catabolite
Activator, whoops,
Activator
Protein.
And so this is, you can imagine,
where a protein, called the
Catabolite Activator Protein,
can bind and perhaps be an activator.
So with that out of the way,
let's think about different scenarios.
Let's think about a scenario
where the E. coli is an environment
where there is no lactose.
So what do you think
should happen over here?
And a lot of these things are very logical
if you just assume that a lot
of biological organisms are quite stingy.
They don't wanna just waste resources.
Well, if there's no lactose,
well, why transcribe the
genes that can be translated
into enzymes for the
metabolism of lactose?
So if there's no lactose,
you can almost do this
as a default state right over here.
You actually have the lac
repressor protein being bound
to the operator.
So this is the lac repressor,
lac repressor right over there,
and so you won't be able
to transcribe these things.
The RNA polymerase won't be
able to get anything done.
No transcription is going to occur.
So no lactose, no transcription,
which makes a lot of sense.
The bacteria, or the bacterium,
this is singular,
doesn't wanna waste resources.
So what do you think should
happen if there is lactose?
So I'll keep this up
here so you can see it.
So lactose present,
lactose
present,
well, you can imagine,
well, you don't want that
repressor around anymore,
and that is indeed what happens,
that you have an isomer of
lactose, called Allolactose.
So if lactose is present,
you're going to have
also Allolactose present,
right over here,
and so that is
Allolactose,
which can act as an
inducer of transcription.
And the way that it acts as an inducer is
if it binds to the lac repressor,
the lac repressor can no longer
bind to the operator site.
When the Allolactose is present,
it will bind to the repressor,
and then the repressor is going
to leave the operator site.
It's not going to be able to bind as well,
and so let me draw that.
So in this case, the operator,
sorry, the repressor I should say.
The operator is where the repressor binds.
So this is the repressor right over here.
You have some Allolactose.
We do that in white.
You have some Allolactose
that has bound to it,
and because of that,
it's not going to bind to the operator,
and since it's not bound to the operator,
well now,
the RNA polymerase can actually
transcribe these genes,
and that's valuable
because by transcribing these genes,
we are going to be able to
metabolize this lactose.
So lactose present,
you have transcription.
Transcription occurs.
Now that's a very high level
simple view of the lac operon,
but there's more involved,
because there's other sugars,
in particular glucose,
which is preferred by the cell.
So, whoops,
moving the wrong part.
There you go.
So let's think about what will happen
in the presence of glucose
and not in the presence of glucose.
So let me write here.
So glucose,
and no glucose,
actually let me do it,
I'll do no glucose first.
So let's see, we have no glucose.
And remember, glucose
is preferred to lactose.
Simpler sugar.
If you have glucose around,
why worry about the lactose?
And then here we have glucose.
We have glucose around.
And we could talk about
both of these situations
in the presence of lactose
or not in the presence of lactose,
but if we don't any lactose around,
then were not gonna have
the Allolactose around,
and then you're just gonna
have the repressor sit
on the operator,
and you're not going to
have any transcription,
and that's going to be whether
or not we have glucose.
So I'm gonna think about no glucose,
but we do have lactose,
plus lactose,
and in here, you have
glucose plus lactose.
Well, the lactose part,
if we have lactose around then we're going
to have the Allolactose around,
and we just covered this scenario.
The Allolactose binds
to the lac repressor,
keeps the lac repressor from
binding to the operator,
and so you have your RNA polymerase
is able to actually
perform the transcription.
But that's not it.
In a situation with no glucose,
you actually are going to
also involve the CAP site.
You're going to have an
activator that's going
to make this happen even more,
because if you don't have glucose around,
man, you really need that lactose.
And so, what you have is something called,
so let me draw this,
the Catabolite Activator Protein,
right over here.
The Catabolite Activator Protein,
and in the presence of Cyclic AMP,
Adenosine Monophosphate.
It's a derivative of ATP,
and so this is that right over there,
Cyclic AMP.
You'll see that come up a lot in biology.
So this is the Catabolite
Activator Protein,
in the presence of C AMP,
and we'll talk about
how Cyclic AMP relates
to glucose in a second.
In that presence,
it is going to bind to this, the CAP site,
and it is going to further
activate the transcription.
So in this situation,
no glucose plus lactose,
you're going to have
even more transcription.
So let me write this down.
Lots of transcription.
Now, I know what you're probably asking.
This is what I first asked myself
when people told me about Cyclic AMP,
"Well, how does Cyclic
AMP relate to glucose?"
Well, I'm not gonna go into
a huge amount of detail here,
but what you need to know here,
and it makes sense,
is that if you have glucose,
so let me write it this way.
If you have high glucose,
high glucose.
I'm having trouble writing.
High glucose,
then that's going to inhibit
the production of Cyclic AMP,
so low Cyclic adenosine monophosphate.
And if you have low
glucose, or no glucose,
it's like a tongue twister.
If you have low glucose,
well, you're not going
to inhibit the creation
of Cyclic AMP,
and so you're going to
have high Cyclic AMP.
So if you have no glucose, or low glucose,
we are in this scenario right over here.
You're going to have higher
concentrations of Cyclic AMP,
which can bind to the
Catabolite Activator Protein,
which then acts as an activator
to allow even more
transcription of the lac operon.
Which, once again, why is it important?
Well, if there's no
glucose or low glucose,
you're really going to need that lactose.
You really wanna transcribe
these genes as much as possible.
Now, what about the situation
where there is glucose and lactose?
Well once again, if there is lactose,
then you are going to have Allolactose,
which is going to be able to
bind to the lac repressor,
and by it binding to the lac repressor,
the lac repressor is not going
to be able to bind to the operator.
And so you do have, once again,
the RNA polymerase is going
to be able to transcribe.
But because you have glucose present,
you're going to have low or,
well I'll just write low,
Cyclic AMP.
And since you have low
or no Cyclic AMP around,
well, that Cyclic AMP
isn't going to be able
to bind to the Catabolite
Activator Protein,
and so the Catabolite
Activator Protein isn't going
to be able to act as an activator.
I know I'm using a lot
of words multiple times.
And so it's not going to
bond to the activator site,
or to the CAP site,
and so you're going to
have less transcription.
Less transcription,
which once again makes sense.
You've got glucose and lactose around.
The cell would prefer to use glucose.
Simpler sugar.
Why waste resources?
You have plenty of energy around,
just go straight to the glucose.
But if you don't have glucose around,
well then use more resources
so that you can digest the lactose.